8 news now breaking news alert
a very busy tuesday morning here at 6 30
right now we're going to start with
breaking news las vegas fire on a scene
of a growing fire this is on the near
east side of the valley so this business
is a lighting fixture store it's on
sahara and maryland causing quite a
snarl with traffic bianca holmen is
there she's been watching them attack
the fire bianca how's it going now
yes it's still very active and like you
said it's a
lighting store it's actually called the
statewide lighting center it's a
lighting production and fixture business
so right now there are three
different fire departments here trying
to control the blaze from the outside
you can see them attacking the fire from
on top there of that ladder we're told
just before 4 am metro parking
enforcement saw smoke coming from the
building when the fire department
arrived they saw a dumpster inside the
building that was on fire and also some
pallets caught on fire so as the fire
grew there was a possibility of the roof
collapsing so that's why they're
fighting the fire from outside and not
inside the building the business owner
told the fire department that the
building was fine when employees left
around 4 pm yesterday
right now we're told there are no
injuries and there was no one that had
to be evacuated from the building
the managers of the surrounding
businesses have given the fire
department access to
their business just in case the fire
spreads but of course the fire
departments are working to contain the
fire ensuring that it does not spread to
the surrounding businesses and they're
still actively working to contain it
investigators will begin to arrive on
scene once the fire is contained and
it's daylight out and they can see and
get inside and that's of course when
we'll find out what sparked the fire
inside of that dumpster in the lighting
store right here on sahara and maryland
parkway back to you guys in the studio
all right